öffentliche kulturförderung
das ist in der schweiz vor allem das
geld das von den gemeinden und kantonen
kommt der bund trägt nur einen zehntel
dazu bei dennoch will er die leitplanken
vorgehen
das tut er detailliert auf 127 seiten
ein hehres ziel
kultur soll alle menschen im lande
reichen nicht nur ein nice to have für
gut ausgebildete und begüterte menschen
so sollen die wichtigsten werke der
großen bundes kunstsammlung in einer
virtuellen nationalgalerie online
zugänglich gemacht werden neu ist ein
programm jugend und musik analog zur
jugend und sport musikunterricht darf
nicht viel kosten und ein label musik
freundlicher lehrbetrieb unterstreicht
die bedeutung von musik
schließlich will der bund auch das lesen
fördern indem er größere kinder und
jugendbuch festivals oder lesetage
unterstützt
kultur soll menschen über die
landesteile hinaus verbinden
ein weiteres ziel der kultur botschaft
wollen kantone das frühfranzösisch
opfern leuten beim bund die alarmglocken
elementar sei das verstehen von sprache
und kultur der anderen landesteilen
daher will er vermehrt literarische
übersetzung zwischen den landessprachen
fördern
im streit ums französisch geht meist das
italienisch vergessen so ist mehr geld
für italienisch als fremdsprache in den
schulen vorgesehen schüler sollen aber
nicht nur sprachen büffeln noch mehr
kriegen sie mit wenn sie für einmal eine
schule jenseits der sprachgrenze
besuchen aber auch später wird das ohr
für fremdsprachige trainiert bleiben
etwa mit mehr westschweizer musikern auf
dem gurten oder deutschschweizer bell
sanierung
ein weiteres ehrgeiziges ziel kultur und
wirtschaft sollen mehr zusammenfinden
das bietet sich insbesondere beim design
und bei den interaktiven digitalen
medien an kulturschaffende profitieren
also von einer innovations- und startup
förderung besonders wichtig sind
auftritte bei internationalen messen und
festivals
die schweiz will sich noch mehr als
innovatives land präsentieren aber auch
die wertschöpfung im inland ist wichtig
das neue label filmstandort schweiz
verspricht mehr geld für schweizer filme
und koproduktionen die in der schweiz
gedreht werden all das kostet
der bund lässt dafür etwas mehr geld
springen als bisher rund 225 millionen
pro jahr